I was lucky this time that there was nobody in
the queue when I, when I first came and requested
the lock. But another time, I may not be that
lucky. There may be somebody else using the lock already, and
if that is the case, then what I would have
to do is to queue myself in this data structure.
And the way to do that, is to indicate by
setting the last pointer, in this list to point to me.
This pointer is always pointing to the last requestor. In this
case, the original case that I showed you, I was the
only requestor that was also last requestor. But now, the queue
has somebody using that particular lock, and so when I come in,
what I'm going to do is, I'm going to set this field of
the lock data structure, the dummy load, the head node, of the
lock data structure to point to me and the last requester.
And I'm also going to fix up the link list so that the
current guy is going to point to me. Why am i doing
this? Well, the reason i do this is because when he is
done using the lock, he needs to reach out and signal me.
What am I going to be doing? I'm going to be spinning. And what
am I spinning on? I'm spinning on the got-it flag. So this
is a data structure that is associated with me, and one of
the fields, you know, is the got-it field in the data structure.
So I'm going to spin on this got-it field in the data structure,
waiting for this guy to set it to two. So,
I initialized it to false when I came in, and form
this request. When I form this request, what I did was
to set myself as the last requester, I'll clear out this
field to indicate that I don't have the lock, and I'll
set up the link list so that the current lock holder
points to me through his next field. And my next field
of course, is null because there is no requester after me.
So once I fixed up this, link list and in this fashion,
then I basically can spend on my got it a boolean variable.